どんどん猫になってしまっちゃうんですね
他の世界を知らなくなっちゃう
猫の考え方やら猫の生き方やら
それにもう影響受けちゃって
共鳴してしまっちゃう
動物のところ 預かって仕事してる人々は
やっぱりものすごくその動物と仲良くなっちゃうんですね
心が共鳴してるんだから
動物も同じ波動出すようになっちゃったら
もうすごく何のこともなく平気で仲間みたいな感じになっちゃうんですね
ですから 全く違う環境でいる人が動物の元を動物が驚いちゃうんです
例えば 私はあまり馬と付き合ったことは全くないんです
馬見たら馬にすぐもう嫌な顔するんですね
他の動物は結構知ってるんだから
まあ側に寄ったって全く知らんふりをしてるんです
いわゆる触っても何かしちゃっても全然もう抵抗しないし
まあただそのままいるんですけど
ゾウさんさえすごい体大きいんだけど
言って喋ったら まあもうなんとなく聞いてるというかね
あるいは無視するかどっち
馬はちょっといつでも何回頑張ってみたんだけど
なかなかもう僕のことをすぐ嫌うんです
それでもしつこく触ろうしちゃったらもう噛んでしまう
噛まれてしまいますから
二 三回ぶん殴ったこともあるんで
人を噛んで何するんですか
その場合はもしかすると
まあ私はやっぱり 自分の国ではね
小さい時から馬と接する機会ってのは全くないんだから
見るのは珍しいことで
ですから 自分その波動がないというかね
馬から見ればもうものすごく気持ち悪い
気持ち悪くなっちゃうんですね
犬とか猫とかは関係なくとかね
鳥でもほとんどもうすぐ仲良くなっちゃう
そういう風に心の共鳴というものがありますから
それは誰でも経験していることで
乗り移るということはないんです
でも世の中でよくあるんですね
これ乗り移ったという現象が
あれは一種の暗示でしょうね
病気ですからね 健康な人には乗り移れませんからね
弱い人の心っていうのはね
他の人の心でね まあ簡単に影響与えることはできますし
共鳴させることもね 簡単にできますし
まあそういう現象でしょうと思いますけど
じゃあ えーと じゃあそろそろアビダンマの世界もテキストの話に戻りましょう
で 心は一つである それは認識する働きは心である
それで心には差はないんだけど
いくらかの違う心は我々には考えることはできます
それは心に映っている心所と呼ぶんですね
心に映える心所の問題
分ければ怒り 嫉妬 悲しみ
楽しみ ただ怒りがある心と楽しみがある心はかなり違うんですね
どちらに違うかというと
この悲しんで知る いわゆる怒って知る
楽しく知るという両方なんですね
あるいは知って楽しい
知って怒ったと 何かを見て楽しかった
何かを見て腹が立ちましたと
それで知るところ 例えば 2つその対象がある
一つは自分がすごい見たい何か好きなもの
もう一つは自分が大嫌いなもの
それで自分見たくて好きなものを見ると見て楽しいと知ることによって楽しみが生まれてくる
見たくないものを見た瞬間で見て怒りが生まれてきて腹が立ってしまったと
それ心が2つなんですね
その場合は  2つというのは
この知る機能は 2種類に見えるんですね
本当は知る機能は同じですけど
この楽しみと怒りが入ってるんだから 2つ考えられます
そういうふうに分けると
もう数え切れないほどの心の種類が考えられます
野菜と同じことなんですね
野菜といえばもうどれぐらい種類あります？と言えばもう知らないでしょうに
世の中ものすごいたくさんありますから
じゃあ果物といったらいくらでもあるでしょうね
種類が 10種類  20種類のところじゃないでしょうし
[背景音楽]そこで今まで食べたことがない植物でも食べられるようにすることもできますから
その場合 野菜の数がまた増えちゃうし
ですから同じ心は別々に考えようとすると
もう数え切れないほどあります
ミミズの心と人間の心を比べてみると
ミミズはちゃんと外の世界を知ってますけど
全く目はない 耳もない
ミミズなのに でもちゃんと
外の世界は知るんですね
その場合は 例えば日に当たったらミミズは死んじゃいますから
すごい危ないところにいますよとちゃんと知ってるんです
でも 太陽の光はミミズはどのように感じるかと
その心と我々は太陽の光はどのように感じるかという感じ方違うでしょ
この太陽の光 我々を見るとすごい気持ちいいものなんですね
こっちよりはこっちにいたいんでしょ
結局は でもミミズの場合は違うんですね
ミミズはこっちじゃなくて
ここら辺にいたんですね
できるだけ日が当たらないところに
そこでミミズの太陽の認識はもう大変怖いもので
私たちは生の 何て言いますか
電線なんか触ったような感じで
もう電気はいいんだけど
もう触っちゃったら死ぬんだから
大変火と同じく 火はありがたいんだけど
遊ぶなと そんな感じで認識するかもしれません
それは私には分かりませんだけど
ミミズはどう感じるか
とにかくすごい恐怖感で感じるでしょうと思います
私たちはそうではなくて
すごい楽しいものとして感じちゃう
どうして人間はやっぱり太陽の光を見る目に入っちゃうと
なんとなく楽しい雰囲気が生まれてくるんですね
そういうことです ですから
心は2種類ありますよと言うと
そうすると我々は過去生が太陽を見てどんな心が現れますかと計算していっちゃうと
これやりきれないでしょうね
フクロウは太陽を見てどういうふうに感じますか？とか
鳥は太陽を見てどういうふうに
もうやり切れるもんじゃないんです
それをそうすると ですから
アビダンマではそういう世俗的な心の分析を置いておいて
仏教に必要な 仏教の教理学に必要な
それから人は修行して解脱を得るために必要なところだけ心理学として説明しているんです
くだらないことは何もない
ミミズは太陽をどう感じたっても
まあそれでも全然関係なくないし
何の意味もないんです
例えば花見て猫はどのように花見ているんですか？猫っていうのは色盲ですか？色を見えないんだそうです
分かりませんですが 僕は個人的には
普通のこういう研究をやっている人々はそう言うんですね
だから猫はどう 例えば私はものすごく色をついているものを着ているし
私は猫を見て 猫が私を見てどう感じるかというのは
別に知っていたっても
まあなんか 意味もないんですね
何かテレビであったんだけど
このキャモフラージュですか
動物にいろいろキャモフラージュで自分を守ってるんだと
ですから このシマウマが砂漠の中で大きな木もないし
ものすごい派手なんですね
シマウマっていうのは
ストリップですからね
ちゃんと白と黒 あんな派手でもライオンにすぐ見つかってバレちゃうんじゃないかと
もうちょっと同じ色でいた方がいいんではないかと
でもあれでライオンに見えないみたいですね
このテレビでなんと工夫してカメラに
カメラの工夫して もうライオンと猫だからもう色は見えないんですね
だからツートーンで見えちゃうんですね
白かもう白の変化として見えちゃうんですね
そうするとちょっとしたこのちょっと高い草葉っぱのところでシマウマがいたら
そういうふうにカメラの光のあれをコントロールするとやっぱり映らないんです
そこでの人間にもそれがあるんです
弱さが 戦争の時はこのよく人間のこの
あれ何て言いますか この視覚の弱さがものすごく使ってたみたいですね
いくら人間は目が鋭いと思ったっても
この戦車とかもう近いところまで持ってこれるんです
ちゃんと人間的にさっぱりわからないようにキャモフラージュできるんだそうで
そこでこの飛行機を守るために
この第二次世界戦争の時はこのキャンバスなんかそういう布の上で飛行機の形を描いて
ざーっとまあ空き場所においておいて
そこで上から見ればちゃんとした戦闘機のように見えるんだと
そこでそこで爆弾をボンボンと落としちゃうんだけど
もう飛行機は他のところには隠すということ
それで飛行機のをこの翼の後ろ上ですか
そちらに何か模様とか何とか書いちゃったら
この下の地面の模様と同じで一緒になっちゃって
上から見たらただの草原として見えるんであって
全然飛行機で見えないんだそうです
そういうふうなもう あれはもう見たテレビで見たところ
やっぱりなるほどと なぜならば人間だからもう見えないんですね
本当に まあそういうことで
まあでもそんなこと戦争のために役に立つかもしれませんだけど
別にただそれだけのことで
別に役に立たないことなんですね
修行には ですから そういう心の分析
仏教ではない 大変高度な心理学がありますよと言ったっても
そういうくだらないことは見つからない
それは覚悟してほしいんです
何の役にも立たないことは見つからない
じゃあ仏教でですから
心はまず４つのカテゴリーに分けます
まずパーリ語 パーリ語の名前書きます
1番目はカーマーヴァチャラ
2番目はルーパーヴァチャラ
3番目アルーパーヴァチャラ
4番目ロークッタラ で
心にはいろいろ言葉使いますけど
だいたいチッタという言葉
使います ですからカーマーヴァチャラチッタ
ルーパーヴァチャラチッタ
アルーパーヴァチャラチッタ
ロークッタラチッタという 4つ
で これ 4つに分けているのはこの次元的なんですね
なんとか次元論みたいなもんなんですね
こういうふうに考える
カーマーヴァチャラ次元とルーパーヴァチャラ次元とアルーパーヴァチャラ次元とロークッタラ次元
じゃあどういう次元かというと
1番目カーマーヴァチャラ
それはもしかすると日本語になると欲懐
欲懐心と書くんですね
欲と懐 心 あまり書けません
上上に書いて こういう名前なんですね
欲界身 色界身 無色界身と出世間身という四つの次元がございます
じゃあこれから説明に入ります
一番目 欲界身 パーリ語の言葉を見てください
カーマという言葉があります
カーマーヴァチャラのアのところまでカー
アーと伸ばさないでカーマだけに止まってください
こちらエ二つ入ってるんです
ア二つ入ってアーになってるんです
ですから カーマっていうのは欲なんですね
欲っていうのは普通の世界で言ったら欲ではないんです
欲っていうのは眼耳鼻舌身の対象なんですね
いわゆる目に見える色
耳に入る音 舌に入る味
体に感じる触 触れるもの
そういうものにこの場合は欲と呼ぶんです
だから言葉見てすぐ分かったぞと思ったら大変危ないんです
いわゆる色声香味触 色声香味触という五つはカーマなんです
このアーヴァチャラ ここからアーヴァチャラというんです
このア取ってここら辺また分かれて
アーヴァチャラっていうのはそこら辺でぐるぐるぐるぐる回ってるという
どこら辺でぐるぐる回ってますか？色声香味触の方で働いているという意味なんですね
縄張り まあ難しそうに聞こえますけど
そんなに難しくないんです
その心 ですから カーマーヴァチャラ心って何ですかというと
この見る心 聞く心 味わう心
嗅ぐ心 それから触れて感じる心
それからそれについて考える頭の中の働き
全部入るんです いわゆる対象なしに成り立たない心
対象なしに知ること不可能な世界
次元 この一番目の次元では
知るためには何か対象
オブジェクトが欲しいんです
英語ではObject Dependentということなんですね
[背景音楽]いわゆる具体的な対象に寄りかかる心
その具体的な対象っていうのは
色 音 香り 寒さ 熱さというものなんですね
じゃあわかりやすく例を出します
人間の心はカーマーアヴァチャーラなんです
欲界心なんですね 我々は全てのものは目で耳で鼻で体で感じて知ってるんです
それで目で見るためには見られるものが必要であるし
耳で知るためには聞こえる音が必要であるし
舌で知るためには味が必要であるし
鼻で知るためには香りが必要であるし
体で知るためには体に何かを触れなくちゃいけない
そのものの熱さ寒さは感じている
硬さとか だから我々はその六つぐらいのことしか知ってないんですね
そこで頭で考えるものはどういうものかというと
よく見てください 頭で考えるのも
見るものについて 聞いたものについて
いくら立派な哲学をやっていたっても
全部見たものについて
聞いたものについて 嗅いだものについて頭で考えてるでしょ
妄想なんかは なんの外の世界と関係なく何か妄想しましたって
そんなことはありえないんです
皆様方一人で頭で考えているものは
もうちょっと客観的に見てください
ごく普通の世の中にあることなんですね
今まで経験したものなんですね
じゃあどのように怒りが生まれますかと
それも何か聞いて それは気に入らなかったんだから怒る
何か見てそれ気に入らなかったんだから怒ったことに
例えば人を見て 何かその人言ったことに
やったことに怒ると だからその人言ったことは耳で知って
その人がやったことは目で知って怒るんであって
それから後で考えてまた怒るでしょ
その時もその人のことを考えて怒るんです
あるいはその人やったことを考えて怒るんです
あるいはその人やらなかったことを考えて怒るんです
誕生日なのにプレゼントを持ってこなかったと思って怒ると
結婚記念日を忘れたと
それやらなかったことだから
それについても怒る ですから
人間の知識世界 全部どんな次元ですか？欲界次元なんです
それはよく明確に知ってる
特にアビダンマに詳しい人であるならば
この人々ということは
なんかへんてこりんなことをおっしゃってる人々たくさんいるでしょ
この神様から特別に自分にメッセージが毎日入ってくるんだとかね
あるいは自分が神様から特別に選ばれてこの世に生まれたんだとか
あるいは自分が神様でこの世に生まれてきたんだとかね
そういう風にこの人々は
だからそこら辺我々は知りませんね
神様が本当に彼におっしゃっているか
あるいは本当に彼が神に選ばれたものかとかね
そこら辺は知りません
日本でもある女の人がいたんですね
プロレスラーですか もう何か神様特別な自分に子供を宿してくれたという
なんとか ですから すごいなんか新興宗教みたいな
新興宗教みたいなキリスト教の中だから
別に新興宗教というほどの大げさなものではなかったんだけど
やっぱりたくさん信者さんがいるんです
あの女の人を拝んだりやっていて
で 妊娠していて 妊娠してる子供は確かに神様だって思ってるんです
で 理由は簡単ですけどね
お医者さんが可能には妊娠不可能でした
プロレスラーでしたからね
全く不可能ですよ もうちゃんと結論出してあったんですね
どこ行ったって それでもそれなのに妊娠しちゃったんです
で じゃあからもうそれだったらもう神様にしかそんなことできないんだと
神様は大変上手ですけどね
で まあそれはそれで だからそういうそこら辺我々はわかりませんね
とにかく 本当に神の子か
どこら辺どこかのこのね
人の子かはわからないんですね
あるいはちゃんと神が耳に何か言ってくるか
そこら辺我々はわからない
ですから我々は関係ない
我々知ってるのは言ってる言葉なんですね
そこで じゃあその人言ってる言葉は何か
何次元かと見てみてください
すぐバレちゃうんです
言ってることはもう片っ端から欲界のことばっかり知ってるんですね
この私は神であると言ってる人はもうすっごいこの
まあ前世物語いうはもうムロヤマさんでしたっけ？前の総理が
彼がなんか昔漁師やってた人よとか
大仏は誰でしたっけ？あの大仏は公明党の国会議員にいる人
え？何？はい いちかわ
大仏で あの それから誰ですか？新進党の人が
え？小沢さん 彼がアジャセーですね
誰？で そういうふうにそうすると
やっぱりこれは欲界に乗り越えてなきゃこの人はそんなこと言えないよと思うでしょ
みんなそう信じてるんですね
でもちょっと見るとよくわかるんです
その宗教団体は政治に参加したいんですね
ですから 自分の信者さんもちゃんと議員として出してるんです
いつか自分が自分の宗教がきちんと天下取ろうと
そのためには徐々に徐々に信者さんを洗脳しなくちゃいけないんですね
そうすると自分が叩きぶっ壊したい
ぶっ壊したい政治家がいるでしょ
で それが単なる政治的な意味で見ると
嫌な人々がいるんですね
それで その人にとってはお坊さんがすごい気に入らない
気に入らないんだけど
いつでも人は言うことをよく聞く
ある面で立派な人なのね
言ったら本当に立派な人ですけど
昔は何さんでしたっけ？この
田中さんじゃなくて亡くなった人
この目白の田中角栄さん
その人々のところで育てられた人々でしょ
ですから この親分の言うことをちゃんと聞いて
なおかつこのすごい能力があって
すごい才能があって だから可愛がられる存在なんですね
だから可愛がられる存在で
だからお釈迦様の時代から見ると
なんとなくぴったしなんですね
アジャセ用の性格に それでもう繋げちゃうんですね
で よくもこの心の波動というか
その思考の方向性っていうのは読んだだけでパッともあ
これとこれ繋げていっちゃうんだと
ただ 村山さんなんかは
いくら社会党であろうとも
皇室に対してはすごく尊敬の心を持っていたんですね
それは日本人誰であろうが
どんな共産主義の人であろうがね
まあ日本人だから 国民性があるんだから
もう皇室に当たる必要はないし
それなりに礼って 何て言いますか
もう敬意の心を持ってるんです
そこで彼が大変 自民党の人々よりも大変皇室の方々についてもう立派な態度を取っていたんです
そこら辺とって 昔々どこかで漁師やっていて
ちゃんと名前とか出てくるんですね
この皇室の方々にそういうとった魚あげたりとか
そういう仕事をしていたんだ
だから今も大変皇室に対してその人は
だからこの私が言うと
皆様はそういうふうにお笑いになりますけど
そのテキスト直接読んでみてください
すぐやられるような ものすごくこの上手に書くんですね
僕は彼をその人を褒めているのは
その書き方なんですね
ものすごく上手なペテン師というかね
詐欺というかね 天才的ですね
そのところだけは それは教育の問題で
ちゃんと教育受けてるんだから
この文章だけは書ける
でも知識はない だからまあどうせ東大に入ったんだから
まあどうせ頭がね まあいいわけじゃないし
いわゆる物事考えると入れませんよ
考えちゃったら追い出されます
いっぱい料知って それをまた繰り返して言えないと入学試験は通らない
それから別な入ったらまあちゃんと勉強するとかしないか別な問題ですけど
東大の人々バカっていうわけじゃなくて
一応入学するためにはもう自分の思考は
入れてくれない ですから
その能力だけあって だから勉強できなかったでしょうね
もしかすると お子さんも同じで
だから二人組んであっちこっちから
この一般的な本 from からね
なんとかなんとか情報取って
あっちこっちあっちこっちつなげてつなげてつなげて喋っている
だからどう喋っても超越した知識から言うものは何もないんです
そこで現代星ですか もういろんな電波望遠鏡とかああだこうだあって
天文学の知識あるんですね
天文学的な知識はまあ新聞から読んで僕にもあるんです
この新聞から冊子から得られるぐらいの範囲で
まあジェズス様はなんとかなんとか星団から来たんだとか
自分が送ったんだとか
ソクラテスはなんとかなんとか星団のなんとかなんとか星に自分を送ったとか
ありっこもない星団の名前とかね
またちゃんと名前をつけてる星団の名前とかね
いっぱい喋る それではもう知識人にはもう納得いかないはずなんです
電波望遠鏡やらいろいろ方法にとって空を見ると
いろんな今まで見えなかった星団とか見つかったところで何か名前付けちゃうでしょ？名前付けなかったらなかなか論文書けませんから
それ見て私はそちらからこの人来たよというのはもうとても簡単ですから
でも普通の人ってやっぱりすごいことを知ってるんだと
で そういうふうに一応例を言っただけで
別にあまり気にする必要ないし
だからこの我々生きてる世の中で
人間よりすごいことをしているというふうな人々はいる
そこでもしその人は本当に人間の領域を超えているかないかと
私たちごく普通の凡人たちが知りたい場合はどうすればいいんですかと
よくやられますからね
偉い人々だから信じるしか方法ないんで
そこでワビサラモの世界を知っているならば
凡人は凡人で この人々は言ってることはどんな次元の話かと
言ってることじゃなくて
この人の知識はどんな次元のことかというと
まあすぐ見えてくるんですが
こういうこういうことだと
そうすると このカーマアヴァチの次元ですか
欲界の次元は乗り越えてないっていうことはもうなんとか分かります
例えばこのそのいわゆる今この悪い例として大変失礼に例に出した人でさえも
よく仏教のことを言っておるんですね
仏教のことといっても
もう大乗仏教で自分に納得した言葉と
初期仏教は中村先生とか書いてるところから読んで納得
納得いったところだけ組み合わせちゃうんですね
残念ながらこの納得いくところは大したところじゃないんです
ごく普通の人の納得いったんだから
組み合わせて これこそ仏教とまた言う
例えば色界の説明は お経を読んでもわからない
無色界の説明 お経を読んでもわからない
どうこう言ってるなら次元というのは絶対わからない
それはもうその世界の人から説明聞いてもらわない限りは全くわからないんです
だから僕ら 僕ら見るのは
もしその人 勘ででもそこら辺感じたらすごい人だと
ある日本の方が自分一人で仏教を勉強した人なんですけど
南伝大乗とか読んで読んで
もう何十年も そこで自分
僕に言ったんです 私はこういうこういう風に勉強して
こういうこういうふうなことを理解しているんだと
一人でなさってるんだから
やっぱりかなりきついと思いますし
教えてもらうのはものすごい簡単ですけど
読んだってもわからないところいっぱいあるんだから
それでもその分析見ると
やっぱり本人がいいところを見つかってるなと
彼の説ですか 自分の仏教に対する考え方
こういう考え方というところはもうやっぱり褒めなくちゃいけない
評価しなくちゃいけないんですね
本当に見つかりにくいところ
ポイントなんかは見つかって
僕はそこら辺はもうさすがすごいなと
ここら辺中心に仏教を説明するのはもう全く間違いないんだ
それは本物の教えだよと
ちゃんと認めてあげたんですね
ですから 別に私が認めてあげなくてもどうでもいいんですけど
やっぱりこのどんな人でも
キリスト教の方でも もし仏教経典読んで
そういう普通の人間に見つからないところ見つかっちゃったら
そこら辺ありがたくやっぱり評価したくはなるんですね
見つかってないと まあ何言ってるんですかと
だから今言ったか人の場合も
ここら辺は全然もう考えたことも読んだことも感じたことも全くないということだけはわかる
その代わりに悟ったよ
ブッダになったよって言葉だけあるんですね
そこで本人も自分が一人で自由に悟るんですね
もともとは悟ったよと言ってなかったんですね
後で本屋に行くと釈尊が悟ったんですと言ってる
じゃあ私も悟らなきゃと
で いきなりもう何日何月何日で自分がもう大悟を得ましたと堂々と書くんですね
それだったらそれなりの過程が必要だし
悟りの内容が必要であるし
それはなし 自分がだけ大仏ならば
自分の弟子たちにこうやればこれ得られますよということを言う必要でありますし
可能か不可能か別として
それはなし ですからもう何のことなく嘘っていうことはもうわかるんですね
ですから こういうのはもう
これアビダンマの悪い使い方なんですけど
まあ人を言うことはどんな次元に入っているかということはすぐ自分で理解できれば
我々はしっかりするんですね
悩むことはないんですね
で あの まあ例えばこの食べ物についてどんなものを食べた方がいいんですかと思っちゃうと
本いくら読んでもまた本がある
心理学の本にしたっても
どうやって心が例えば才能はどのこの世に生まれますよと本いっぱいあるでしょうに
未知の能力の挑戦という本もあるんです
あるいは注意力ですか
脳の驚くべき力とかね
そういうものを見ると
もうどこまで読んでも気が済むかというと
もうキリがないんですね
あれも読みたい これも読みたい
IQ なんか新しい本 またアメリカの本
また翻訳されちゃって大変なんですね
そうすると人間というのは
このすべての本を読むわけにいきませんし
読めないし 読んでも掴めないし
あれもいや これもいや
これもいいや あれもこれも悪くない
あれもよくないって もうものすごい混乱状態に陥るんですね
それだったらいい方法
まず基本をつかむ アビダンマの基本を言ってるんですね
例えば なんで人間に能力才能ないかというと
あまりにも概念にとらわれているんだからなんですね
知識にとらわれてるんだからなんですね
概念知識というのは過去の経験であって
過去の経験について自分の解釈であって
過去の経験に自分の解釈があって
その自分の解釈にしっかりつかまっちゃうと
全然進歩はなし ですから心はそのまんま進化しない
そこで何とかして概念にとらわれることをなくなっちゃったら
まあ全部 OK なんですね
知りたいものはすぐ知られるという
それ法則を知っておけばそれで十分なんです
食べ物のことを言ったんだけど
食べ物であれで何であろうか
我々はストレスでもう落ち着きがない場合は
もう食べ物を当たってしまっちゃうんですね
食べ過ぎになるのも精神的な不安定だからなんですね
問題いっぱいあって 仕事はあってやりすぎなくてとか
悩み苦しみがあると もう何でもかんでも食べちゃう
あるいは何も食べないで拒否するとか
どっちかになる で そうじゃなくて
すごく心落ち着いていると
何食べても体にはちゃんと入って
それは適当に分解して健康状態を守られる
食べる物はあーだこーだ探す必要ないんです
例えば落ち着いて味わって食べると
何でもすごく美味しいんです
たとえご飯にしたっても
食べる食べるたびにちゃんと噛んで味わって食べると
例えば回箸からご飯運んだならば
種類味を味わえるんです
で 我々は焦ってるんだから
種類味は全然知らないんです
ただ 体験もしていないのにご飯は美味しいやと言うんですね
僕らには落ち着いて体験してみようと
そうすると おかずなしにご飯だけを食べても体には問題ないんです
ですから この基本的な法則さえ理解しておけば
問題 ほとんどの問題終わってしまうんですね
例えば瞑想と気功はどうしますかと
瞑想とあのいろいろあの鍼と体のあれ
何て言いますか 鍼を刺すところはツボ
それはどういう関係ありますかとか
瞑想とチャクラの関係はどうですかとか
そこを探し求めていっちゃうと切りがなくなっちゃうんです
じゃあツボを発見したんだから
中国人もすごい超能力を持っていたんではないかとかという風になってきて
切りがなくなってしまっちゃう
それよりは心の働きと体の関係はどうですかとわかったら
全部説明できるんです
簡単に 仏教でそういうやり方で
この基本的な法則を明快に明確にしようとしているんです
そこで理解できると ですから
このカーマーヴァチャーの欲界の心を勉強すると
だいたい世の中の知識のことというのは結構こんなもんだよとぐらい理解できる
じゃあ人間みんな色界の次元にいるんです
すべての人間が なぜならば人間が目耳鼻
あるいはいわゆる体という物体媒介として知る
体という道具さえ 道具なければ知ることは不可能なんですね
人間に 脳細胞という道具なければ
どうやって どのように考えられますか？目という道具なければ
どういうふうに世の中見えますか？だから道具で知ってるんです
それはもう一つの例なんですけど
このこの科学はすごく発展しているんだと
言って みんな道具ばっかり作ってるんですね
科学っていうのは 電波望遠鏡を作る
電子顕微鏡を作る 電子顕微鏡で原子まで見る
電波望遠鏡を使ってものすごい宇宙の遠い遠いところまで見てしまう
本当は見えないんです
見えないんだけど なんとか道具を使って
この道具から得る情報から道具が出す信号
信号から知ってるよ知ってるよと思う
例えば電波望遠鏡で原子の構造を見ても見えないんです
線々 実体を 見えないんだけど
誰でもあれは嘘やって思わないんです
なぜならば 電波電子望遠鏡がある電子の流れを流れて
この流れがあって それはあの電子原子に当たってまた返ってくる
あるいは返ってこないとか
そこら辺 あるいはこの流れがちょっと変化する
原子に当たったら原子もエネルギーだから
同じぐらいの細かいエネルギーだったら
まあちょっとそこら辺でちょっと曲がったりはする
そこら辺は計算する 計算して
それはまた違う この計算結果が違う電気信号に変えちゃって
それはモニターに映してもらう
そうするとモニターで何か映像のようなものが出来上がっちゃう
その映像で あ 原子っていうのはそんな形ですねとか驚いちゃうんです
原子はそんな形じゃないんです
でも そう見てしまうんですね
例えば一番いいというのは
磁石のマグネットパワーですか
このありますね 流れてるんですね
そこで磁石の NとS が近寄っておくと
きついこのエネルギーがきつく直線でついてるんですね
直線でついてるんだけど
地球の磁石によってもかすかなそれがあるはずなんです
真ん中ではなくて外側に
もし他の磁石 線か何か出しちゃうとそこでぶつかるんですね
そこをテレビモニターで見ると
磁石と磁石の間ではきつい塊があるように見えちゃうんです
だからそこら辺 我々は目で確かめることできます
我々にとっては磁石と磁石の間では全然きつい固い塊は何もないんです
電波望遠鏡ではなくて
電子顕微鏡の論理を使って見ると
そこら辺ものすごいきつい塊があるんですね
ちょっと真ん中ちょっと膨らんだ
こんな感じの塊が出ちゃうんですね
だからまあそういう まあそれは人間の世界で人間がそういうふうに論理を使って物事を知ったりはする
いわゆる道具を使って知ったりはする
だから知る 知ってる知識と実態が似ているかないかってのは
こんなこと知らないです
誰でも これはもうしょうがないんです
で 宇宙はあーだこうだというのは
単なる電波望遠鏡に入るいろいろ宇宙線ですか
それについていろんな計算して計算して
計算結果はもう写真として出るだけのことなんですね
それも自分好きな色に
色に 色にすればいいんだからね
赤くするか白くするか
それはもう科学者の勝手なんです
だからって 宇宙のそのところは赤いか白いか
それはわからないし 例えばブラックホールというのは本当にブラック
黒いかと 誰がわかってるんですか
ただ 電波は通らない 光は通らない
だからブラックというだけのことであって
もしかするとものすごい明るいかもしれませんよ
なんか明るいはずだそうです
ブラックホールは 残念ながら外から見えない
それだけ これで言っても巨大なものだから
ものすごいエネルギー固まってあって
だから光はあります ものすごいエネルギーの塊だから
強烈な